الولايات المتحده تترك اوكرانيا وحيده
وتقرر دعم اسرائيل بينما كيف تعلن
اقترابها من ايقاف العمليات القتاليه
المخابرات الامريكيه تصدر تقريرا عن موعد
المواجهه المباشره مع ايران المقاومه
العراقيه تدخل خط الحرب الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه دفعه ثانيه من المساعدات
الانسانيه الروسيه الى غزه نتنياهو يدرس
طلبا امريكيا بهدنيه انسانيه اردوغ ان
يصرح لا يوجد مصطلح يمكن ان يشرح الوحشيه
التي تحدث هناك حامله طائره فرنسيه تتحول
الى مستشفى ميداني في مياه غزه لبنان يعلن
استعداده للحرب ضد الجيش الاسرائيلي
الطائرات الامريكيه تحلق في سماء غزه ما
الهدف المقاومه الفلسطينيه تلتف على
الوحدات الاسرائيليه من النقطه صفر بعد
اعلان اسرائيل تطويق مدينه غزه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقر بارتفاع خسائره حيره
امريكيه بين خيارين احلاهما مر هذا هو
الموقف الامريكي الحائر بين مواصله دعم
اوكرانيا كما تعهدت واشنطن على الدوام او
تحويل انبوب المساعدات نحو تلبيب هنا
اظهرت نتائج التصويت ان مجلس النواب
الامريكي الذي يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون وافق
على مشروع قانون منفصل لتخصيص ما يقرب من
14 مليار و300 مليون دولار كمساعدات
لاسرائيل دون اي اشاره الى اوكرانيا في
الوقت ذاته رجحت المخابرات الامريكيه ان
ايران تقوم بدراسه وقياسه ردها على
العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في قطاع
غزه لتجنب المواجهات المباشره مع اسرائيل
او الولايات المتحده وذكرت شبكه سي ان ان
نقلا عن مسؤول امريكي مطلع على بيانات
المخابرات الامريكيه حول المنطقه ان طهران
تعلم ان تصعيد الصراع مع اسرائيل او
الولايات المتحده سيؤدي الى صدام مباشر من
ايران الى الجار العراقي حيث كانت
المقاومه في العراق قد اعلنت عن استهداف
القاعده العسكريه الامريكيه القريبه من
مطار اربيل بطائرتين مسيرتين وقالت
المقاومه ان الطائرتين المسيرتين اصابت
اهدافه ما بشكل مباشر لتعلن المقاومه
العراقيه ايضا استهداف مدينه ايلات
الاسرائيليه مضيفه انها ستبدا من الاسبوع
القادم مرحله جديده تستهدف فيها قواعد
اعدائها بشكل اوسع واشد نصره لشعب فلسطين
وانتقاما للضحايا وبينما قالت صحيفه
التايمز اوف اسرائيل نقلا عن تقرير نشرته
قناه كان العبريه ان رئيس وزراء اسرائيل
بنيامين نتنياهو يدرس طلبات الولايات
المتحده لوقف اطلاق نار انساني لفتره
قصيره في غزه وقال نتنياهو ان اسرائيل
ترفض اقرار اي وقف مؤقت لاطلاق النار في
غزه ما لم يتم الافراج عن المحتجزين لدى
حرك كه حماس لننتقل الى لبنان حيث اكد
رئيس البرلمان اللبناني نبي بري ان ما
تقوم به المقاومه على الحدود ياتي ضمن
قواعد الاشتباك لافتا الى انه اذا اراد
الاسرائيليون التوسيع العمليه فنحن جاهزون
لذلك ليخرج الامين العام للمقاومه
اللبنانيه حسن نصر الله ويصرح ان الجبهه
اللبنانيه تجذب ثلث القوات البريه
لاسرائيل ونصف قواتها البحريه مضيفا ويمكن
ان نذهب الى اي خيار في اي وقت من الاوقات
في قطاع غزه اعلنت وزاره الصحه مقتل
9227 فلسطينيا واصابه
33516 اخرين منذ السابع من اكتوبر ونقل
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان هناك
جرائم ضد الانسانيه ترتكب في قطاع غزه
معتبرا انه لا يوجد مصطلح يمكن ان يشرح
الوحشيه التي تحدث هناك اما في فرنسا
فاعلن وزير القوات المسلحه الفرنسيه
سيباستيان ليكنو انه سيتم ارسال حامله
المروحيات ديكس ماد قباله سواحل قطاع غزه
وذلك لدعم المستشفيات في القطاع الفلسطيني
من جهه اخرى قال مسؤولان امريكيان لصحيفه
نيويورك تايمز ان الولايات المتحده تنفذ
طلعات بطائرات استطلاع مسيره في سماء قطاع
غزه بحثا عن الرهائن لدى حركه حماس واكد
مسؤولو البنتاجون ان هذه هي المره الاولى
التي تعمل فيها طائرات امريكيه بدون طيار
فوق مشددين على ان الطائره المسيره ليست
مسلحه ولا تدعم الانشطه الهجوميه للجيش
الاسرائيلي في المنطقه فيما كان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن قد وصل
تلبيب للمره الثالثه منذ بدء الحرب على
غزه وذلك لبحث حق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن
نفسها والعمل على ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه لغزه وفق بيان الخارجيه
الامريكيه هناك في مصر وصلت طائره مساعدات
روسيه الى مطار العريش الدولي وذلك تمهيدا
لارسالها الى قطاع غزه وهي محمله ب 28 طنا
من المستلزمات الطبيه وبعد اعلان اسرائيل
تطويق مدينه غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقر
بارتفاع عدد قتلا الى 24 بينما تؤكد
المقاومه استمرار التصدي حيث قال المتحدث
باسم المقاومه ابو عبيده ان المقاومه
تمكنت من الالتفاف خلف خطوط العدو والهجوم
عليه من النقطه صفر وفق تعبيره واضاف انه
تم تدمير قوامه كتيبه دبابات وقتل واصابه
عدد من جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي كما اضاف
ابو عبيده ان اعداد القتل من جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي اكبر بكثير مما تعلنه قيادتهم
وفق تعبيره فيما قالت اليزابيث راسل
المتحدثه باسم المفوض الاعلى للامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان ان اسرائيل ترتكب
العديد من جرائم الحرب المختلفه في غزه
هذا وكانت قناه الجزيره قد افادت باستهداف
بوابه مجمع الشفاء الطبي بمدينه غزه
بصاروخ ما ادى لسقوط قتلى وجرحى من جهته
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في غزه ان
القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف سيارات اسعاف في
اكثر من موقع في المقابل قالت وسائل اعلام
عبريه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي نقل حوالي 260
جنديا مصابا الى المستشفيات كجزء من حوالي
150 عمليه انقاذ جويه وبريه بالتعاون مع
القوات البريه ووحدات النخبه في حدود
لبنان افادت مصادر امنيه ان 25 بلده
لبنانيه تعرضت لغارات اسرائيليه من طيران
حربي ومسيرات وبلغ عمق بعض تلك البلدات 10
كيلومترات في جنوب لبنان من حرب فلسطين
التي تعتبر حرب الشرق الاوسط باكمله الى
حرب اوكرانيا حيث قال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان اوكرانيا تبيع الاسلحه
الى الشرق الاوسط بما في ذلك الى حركه
طالبان ومن تلك المنطقه تنتقل هذه الاسلحه
الى اي منطقه اخرى في العالم بينما قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
العقيد جنادي كوفالينكو ان اوكرانيا لن
تتمكن من مواصله الاعمال القتاليه اذا
توقفت الدول الغربيه عن دعم نظام كيف
وذكرت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان شركاء نظام
كيف حول اهتمامهم الى النزاع بين اسرائيل
وحركه حماس الفلسطينيه في الميدان اعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه ان مقاتلاتها والدفاعات
الجويه دمرت ع طائرات حربيه ومروح
اوكرانيه خلال الاسبوع الماضي فيما بلغ
اجمالي خسائر الجيش الاوكراني نحو
[موسيقى]
جنديا